I'll give a little introduction Dr Golan
broshi is an author and professor at one
for Israel Bible College born and raised
in a kibbutz which is kind of like a
Jewish commune to Jewish parents uh he
came to Faith In Jesus Dr broshi thank
you so much for coming on the show
praise the lord it's a pleasure Michael
so Dr Brushy I grew up in New York the
vast majority of my friends were Jews uh
mostly of the secular or kind of
reformed like don't take it all that
seriously variety I've gone to some of
their weddings where even the rabbis
were eating scallops and bacon you know
so that that kind of General atmosphere
and a smaller subset of my Jewish
friends
have been Messianic Jews in the sense
that they've converted to Christianity
in some way or another you know they're
of the seat of Abraham but some have
become Catholic uh some have have gone
into different versions of protestantism
and uh so you are now among my friends
who have done that ethnically Jewish uh
and believe in Jesus and you are
specifically a Messianic Jew
so what does that mean
yes so we believe you don't convert to a
different religion you convert from your
sins you convert back to God so being a
Messianic Jew just means that you are
born to Jewish parents and you happen to
believe that Yeshua is the Messiah not
for the Jews for the entire world
beautiful a beautiful uh summary and I
certainly agree with you that you know
that most basic statement of course uh
but that means then that you're not
converting away from Judaism that in
your view your
I guess you're just you're fulfilling
Judaism
Michael you have no idea the depth of
what you just asked me because still in
Israel today the the there's an argument
what is a Jew is Judaism an ethnic thing
is it a religious thing
and and I'll tell you is it is it an
ethos or an ethnos and we believe that
there's two Judaism competing there's
rabbinic Judaism versus Messianic
dualism which is the Judaism for God
that's the question and we in one for
Israel want to convince our people here
in Israel that Yeshua is the Messiah
fulfilled fulfilled and was docked in
the Bible in the Jewish scriptures
so what convinced you uh other than say
the Holy Spirit you know our Lord
himself you know what convinced you that
Jesus really is who he says he is
so I'll tell you what happened then and
you write that the um the bottom line is
that the Holy Spirit opened my eyes
that's the bottom line but I was I was
finding myself in a Yeshiva in a school
where you where you learned the talmud
and this is exactly the time where um a
Korean friend
told me to read the New Testament if I
want to know she challenged me she said
if you want to know what I believe read
the New Testament so can you imagine in
the morning I'm studying the talmud in
the Yeshiva and in the evening I'm
sitting in the kibbutz reading the New
Testament and all of a sudden the penny
drops and I and I understood that I'm
I'm reading two judaisms each Judaism
claims that it's the right Judaism of
God and the more I studied in the
Yeshiva I understood that the only
Judaism that that fulfills the Messianic
hope of the of the Old Testament could
be the New Testament and I think that's
exactly what the Disciples of Yeshua
saw when they saw Yeshua they said we
found we found him that Moses and the
prophets talked about
so you this reminds me of a historical
matter there's something called the
disputation of Paris in 1240 and this
was under the reign of Saint Louis Louis
IX of France and there was a Jew named
Nikolai danan and he was but he was not
a rabbinical Jew or a talmudic Jew he
was a karate Jew and so he was all Torah
focused not talmud focused and he
basically came to the conclusion that
you came to he said Jesus is who he says
he is he's actually is the Jewish
Messiah and he converted he I think he
became a Franciscan you know he
converted to a Catholic religious order
and then he held this big public debate
or he got the authorities to hold a big
public debate where the Christians were
debating with the rabbinical Jews with
the rabbis uh over the talmud and so I
think even when you say there are
different kinds of Judaism most people
that's going to be the first time
they've ever heard such a thing so
where does it all come from I mean what
are the what are we've gone all the way
back to Abraham here what are what are
the various lines that have that have
come afterward
that's um that's an amazing question
because now you know Israelis Israelis
Scholars religious and secular are
realizing that in the first century
there was no one Judaism there were many
judaisms and we read about them in the
New Testament the Pharisees the
Sadducees these scenes many judaisms but
the center of Judaism of biblical
Judaism was the temple the priest the
sacrificial system when the temple went
down there was there were only two two
Judaism standing Messianic Judaism and
rabbinic Judaism and what the what the
scholars in Israel are now saying and
I'm not talking about believer Scholars
I'm talking about religious rabbinic
Scholars and and secular they're saying
that they're starting to talk about the
um the Messianic roots of the rabbinic
faith can you imagine that
because because the writings of the New
Testament and I'm talking about Jewish
writings I consider the New Testament to
be Jewish writings the writings of the
New Testament came hundreds of years
before the writings of the rabbis so
this is another thing that I think is
unusual for people to hear I remember
when I first encountered this it totally
shook my view of the history of religion
which is that you think of
people think of Judaism as one thing as
monolithic and as predating Christianity
but but as you point out you know the
talmud is written down centuries
afterward so obviously something is
going on here now I think the the
rabbinic argument is that well yes but
the talmud was passed down orally before
that and so it happened to be codified
centuries later but it actually you know
it dates back much much earlier
yeah you can always argue for an oral
law the only problem is that you can
never find the aura law in the Bible so
we have Moses we have Moses 1500 years
before the time of Christ and then all
of a sudden we have the aura law in the
first the first in the First Century A.D
so we have
1500 years of of a missing link of the
there's no oral law anywhere until the
Pharisees are coming with that idea and
by the way Yeshua the Yeshua the Messiah
Jesus himself rebuked the Pharisees and
the scribes in Mark 7 for in Yeshua said
by your tradition and he meant the aura
law by your tradition you making the
word of God of non-effect so we saw it
we see again that there's a rivalry in
the family it's a family dispute a
Jewish dispute between two kind of
Judaism which Judaism is the is the true
Judaism of God and I believe that
messian of course you can say
Christianity is the the only the only
truth from God so what do you say to uh
rabbinic Jews who who argue that well
Jesus doesn't actually fulfill the
prophecies in the Old Testament I mean
look obviously I'm Christian I certainly
think he does but uh you're Jewish
ethnically you're in Israel you how
would you answer that
so here in one for Israel we have many
we get many questions from Israelis that
ask those questions they ask how can
Yeshua be the Messiah I mean isn't
Christianity for the Gentiles and I and
I tell them it's also for the Gentiles
but it's for the Jew first and by the
way remember the debate remember the the
Disciples of yeshuaian Acts they were
astonished when they saw Gentiles
embracing the faith now I tell I give
challenge I I get I I put a challenge in
front of my Israelis friends the
non-believers friends and I tell them
give me one one more Rabbi in the
history of the world that through him by
him Gentiles all around the world know
the god of Abraham do you know of any
other Rabbi beside Yeshua that through
him Gentiles all across the world like
like Michael no the god of Abram know
the Bible do you know of any other
candidate and none of them can give me
an answer there's only one candidate
only Yeshua the Messiah
that rose from the dead that's that
that's a beautiful take because you know
I think a lot of the focus is on well
okay how about this Prophecy in the book
of Isaiah so you know the fact he's born
of a virgin he is born in Bethlehem he's
you know you just go through the entire
Litany of prophecies that Christ
fulfills in himself uh you're saying
will also look ahead look at history you
know the Christian for Christians
history is extraordinarily important
unlike other religions especially
Eastern religions the religion is not
just a philosophy or poetry or something
outside of time but the Incarnation and
the crucifixion the resurrection that
that's the pivot of history that that
you know the the cross is the Axel on
which the entire world turns and you're
saying well look afterward what comes
later
the whole world was converted to the god
of of Abraham
exactly and you know one of the biggest
challenge we get from from Israel is
even even family members is but but but
aren't you aren't you making Yeshua God
aren't you making Jesus a God and and
we're saying wait a minute did he rest
did God resurrect him from the dead
because it all stands or fall on the
resurrection if God raised him why would
God raise a false prophet from the dead
why would God do that and of course you
know most Israelis like like I did
before I got saved most Israelis never
read the New Testament from themselves
most of them never read the Bible the
entire Bible but and they don't know
anything about it but I asked him why
would God raise him from the dead so of
course they asked me how do you know he
wrote he raised them from the dead how
do you know Yeshua really and I and I
tell them but we have Jewish testimonies
from the first centuries in the Bible in
the New Testament we have a collection a
library of Jewish testimonies Jews that
were willing to die AI yeah on the fact
that they saw the Risen Messiah and 500
are only by his name yep exactly right
exactly yes I mean they don't have an
answer I could see how it would be
jarring because you see it in the New
Testament too which is when Christ is
being uh interrogated by the Pharisees
and he's saying Abraham was happy to see
my day says you're not even 50 years old
right as Abraham happy to see your day
and he says before Abraham was I am one
can see either he is who he says he is
or that is or or people are going to
Rend their garments or both
so I'll tell you what happened so I have
a religious friend that I meet almost
every night in the park when I take the
dog the dog out and he tells me he tells
me the the biggest problem the biggest
problem he has is with with with the
identity of Yeshua the identity of
Yeshua easy easy if if he is God does
God have a body because most Jews would
have a hard time believing and I tell
them what about Genesis what about Adam
and Eve hiding because they hear God
walking in the garden they hear him
walking what about Abram that washed
Abram that washed God's feet and gave
him food to eat and then argued with God
and it says it says the the implicit
name of God in Hebrew it says the
implicit name argued with God standing
against God arguing for Sodom and
Gomorrah so you know what they tell me
it's metaphorical it's only metaphorical
but the problem is if everything is
metaphorical where's the truth where's
the actual you know what I mean
metaphorical ultimately referring to
what I mean the old you have to answer
that question eventually uh Dr Brushy I
have about three more hours that I want
to talk to you for but unfortunately the
time is up we will certainly have to
have you back I really really appreciate
you taking the time uh where can people
find you
well in one for Israel we have we have
praised the Lord we have a a bible
college and you can find it one for
Israel and Dot org I think one for
Israel um YouTube page just click one
for Israel and you'll uh you'll find me
and Michael I think and I hope it's the
beginning of a wonderful friendship
absolutely absolutely Dr broshi thank
you so much and to all of you out there
I'm Michael noses the Michael Knowles
show see you tomorrow
[Music]